what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube
channel I missed you guys it has been a
long hard Road all right I want to First
make sure my chat is working I want to
make sure I'm live please put a one in
the
chat if you guys can hear me see me
everything's good everything's good okay
so guys guys guys I'm sorry I had to
take I had to take some time off I had
to go home I had to go home I had to go
home
[Music]
for a number of reasons really
one I did a year of shows okay one in oh
my gosh there's so many of you one in
the chat thank you thank
you you guys stop
it you guys are so
helpful you guys are the best the best
okay okay okay
okay okay first of all sorry I'm I'm
gonna start over first of all thank you
guys for watching I first wanted to say
we are so close to 2 million subscribers
on this channel I have been on YouTube
for two years and it is crazy to me that
in two years we got to 2 million
subscribers so first of all I wanted to
thank every single one of you for being
awesome for watching this whole time um
and I wanted to talk a little bit
about really what's been going on the
last two months since we got demonetized
so um about two months ago now I
received word that I was demonetized now
a lot of people are putting out stories
about why I was I was demonetized
they're all fake they're all fake news
they don't care about what's true um I
was I can't say it on YouTube obviously
obviously but I'll say this I was
demonetized for speaking about a certain
lgbtq plus
group now I I get to reapply in about
three weeks I'm really hopeful about it
I've spoken to the Reps I understand
what I got to do so I am very hopeful
but for the time being it's not overly
helpful to have a lot of content to find
Pearl saying something maybe that would
not help us with that
remonetization but for the time being we
are accepting cash app in venmo okay if
there's anything else we should add to
that maybe we'll add PayPal next time or
something um there was somebody my
first you guys are so nice my very first
cash app person Edward
fizzle thank you thank you thank you
thank you you know and you guys have
really seen me you guys have been with
me through it all like you saw me back
in Chicago where I started everything I
was doing like 10 reactions a day
watching you know and just watching all
this red pill stuff watching pickup some
of you might have even seen me go to a
pickup artist event um you guys saw me
recruit for the shows saw me start the
shows and you know every day I'm really
grateful for you guys you guys are
amazing you guys are
awesome
um now I know many of you will
say so I want to tell you guys more
about what has been going on the last
two years because for the last two years
the media has just made up a certain
narrative about me and I thought about
this the other day I don't think there
is a group that I didn't piss off in the
past two years on the
internet I can't think of one and it's
really interesting
because um it's really interesting
because a lot of people you
know they go off on these tangents they
say things that are deliberately not
true and the last two years I've just
been ignoring it you know I've been
ignoring it I've just been trying to you
know my whole Journey on YouTube I hate
the word Journey but I'm going to use
today was really fueled by wanting to
figure out what was true about the world
and I think that's what you guys came
here for you know there was just a sense
of genuine curiosity I never tried to
pretend to be smarter than anyone or
better than anyone I just was trying to
figure out what was true and what wasn't
true and when I started looking for what
was true what wasn't true you know I
figured out that men are discriminated
against you know that women live life on
easy mode I figured out that you know we
have an entire generation of kids that
have essentially been raised without
fathers because even if there is a dad
in the
home even if there is a dad in the
home so many times he is bending to the
will of his woman you know I learned
what I believe is the natural order of
the world I also learned that you know
feminism is here to
stay and unfortunately I'm not sure
there's any going back there might be
we can hope for it but I don't see any
Trends pointing that
way um I'm oh this one okay and you
know I just think it's fair that my Audi
audience that my a no I didn't get
cloned what you guys are saying I got
cloned no what are you stop making up I
there are enough conspiracy theories
about me out there you know pearls this
pearls that I mean you guys have seen it
all if I Google my name on Google on
YouTube it says I'm a million
things a million things but you know I
know who I am you guys know me through a
screen and a lot of you have been here
for the Long Haul so where did I go
where did Pearl go so the last two years
I have worked so incredibly hard to
build this channel that
honestly I was tired guys I been doing
shows for two
years and I got to be
honest I was tired of talking to these
hoes I'm sorry I'm sorry guys I can't do
another I can't do another not all women
are like that now when I first started
and I think a lot of the reaction TMZ
channels would pick this up they would
hear me say oh and I thought this when I
first started reacting to Red Pill stuff
I I would watch myON and I would think
myON why don't you just say it nicer why
don't you just communicate better and I
in my arrogance I thought oh pearls a
woman I can just communicate
nicer no it does anyone that's watched
my show actually knows I'm I'm pretty
polite I'm a pretty nice person and it
bites me in the ass because these chicks
take advantage of it if you give them an
inch if you give them an inch they take
a mile so it doesn't matter how nice you
say it so yeah after two years of this
guys I was tired I was tired I needed to
take a little bit of time off so I went
home and you know when you go home guys
there's one thing that I think you can't
gain anywhere else in the world but at
your home and that's why I think it's
really sad the mothers that have made
very selfish selfish decisions where
kids cannot go home
okay stop making up no I'm not
pregnant I'm just saying I'm just say
stop with the conspiracy theories enough
enough anyways so when you go home you
get perspective and you realize
that
you realize that you
know the city and outside of the city is
different because I grew up I grew up on
40 acres I had chickens I had you know
and I've been in London for two years
playing
volleyball and so when I go home it's
like home's where the heart is home is
great okay
um and what I learned when I went home I
always learned lessons from my dad and I
get a little frustrated I would say dad
you know all these people they believe
all this stuff about me it's not even
true they have all these TMZ these crazy
reaction channels what do I do and my
dad's so funny he's so simple yet such a
funny man he simply says who
cares who cares it doesn't matter most
people in life you don't deal with and I
said dad dad dad dad but you won't
believe leave these girls they're so
crazy and like I just I can't do these
shows anymore I I am so tired I'm
exhausted I don't have the patience for
it anymore and he said so
don't now I do think no I'm not AI stop
it stop
it I'm tired I'm tired of these
theories no I'm not
Ai No I know I
don't I mean I could go through them do
you know what I mean
and no no I'm not Ai No I you know no
I'm not a racist anti-semitic colonizer
didn't do any of that it's just crazy
you guys are CRA
anyways so my my dad's just the guy and
so my thought moving forward on this
channel I really wanted to document
going through what it was like getting
demonetized
because really as a Creator
guys that is like a death
sentence it really is you know you I I
had to think about all of the time I
spent hours of my years of my
life making video after video after
video 10,000
videos and
unfortunately unfortunately what this
does does is it does give you
know reaction channels you know ample
content they'll come through hours and
hours of footage trying to find one one
thing anyways
anyways no that doesn't matter doesn't
even matter the point I'm making the
point I'm
making is I wanted to
document the last two three years on
YouTube now we're also in the process of
doing a divorce documentary and guys I I
honestly have been so busy the last two
years it had to go on the back burner
for a while and that that really is
something I want to put out so the first
documentary I'm putting out is about my
YouTube and the second one we're doing
is the divorce documentary that should
be
out I don't want to promise a date let's
say next six months let's six months um
now
the other thing is we are I mean we've
talked about this before we do have the
network coming in we have Troy Francis
we have Nazarene they have been creating
content creating videos um Christine as
well um for the past couple of months
that's been awesome and I'm also going
to make a studio in Chicago so I'm able
to when I go home we want to be able to
have more American guests um and in the
next six
months I think we're going to do a
call-in show so I was thinking two or
three times a week and I want to know
what time of day you guys would be best
for you guys in the
chat what time of day give me give me
eastern time in the chat okay um and I
want to do a call-in show and I want to
ask you guys you know your opinions on
certain topics I think I really want
to interact more with not just the
people from London I really want to get
people from all all over the world okay
people that agree that disagree and we
can just talk about today's problems
what is life like for you in modern
society okay okay no I did not make up
an make an only fans oh my God stop it
stop it
I enough enough with this craziness
okay okay so the next six months one I'm
G to start with the Callin show two
[Music]
um no I'm not an
alien okay this is this is getting
annoying this is getting annoying I
don't need this nonsense all right am I
an Elon Musk Tesla
bot oh my gosh
whatever whatever whatever whatever okay
so
so anyways long story short
documentaries are coming out we're going
to do a call fall in show and and and I
want to do some more one-on-one
interviews so that's that's what's to
come in the future let me know if you
guys like that you know feel free to
send a cash app to support you know you
you awesome
people um okay so today what I wanted to
talk about actually though so today's
topic any other questions in the
chat you
know any other questions let me know
um you want to clone me okay this is
weird no I no I didn't get
cloned um okay people keep asking what
happened to my tooth yeah guys I I took
out I had a I had a thing that covered
it I took it out it's it's not that
chill out okay
um how's the family the family's good
really good to see the family
um you know um I I was teaching my
sister some basketball moves so that was
great am I interviewing Andrew Andrew
Tate you know I'd like to nothing
scheduled but it'd be good to you know
do another one with him okay so today I
want to talk about
my the hard thing that I have with
religion I guess how would I how would I
describe this better I want to talk
about
about the
difficulty that I have with modern
religion
okay
now I was raised a
Catholic okay and growing up in the
Catholic church I can't say I ever
really heard about
patriarchy I can't say I ever really
heard about submitting to your husband
not really and if you did it was like a
mutual submission maybe they did and I
forgot it I wasn't paying attention I
don't know but I'm saying from my memory
don't remember too much of
it and the problem we have is what I
found is that's a lot of Christian folk
want to go back to the
1920s even though that was the first
sexual Revolution now this sounds nice
okay this this sounds nice all right
guys just go to church find you a good
Christian
woman right I mean why don't you just
find a girl that prays
fellas get in the chat put a one in the
chat if you found a girl that prays now
what I found why I found that this
advice sucks is because the women of
today are not the women of
yesterday you know I remember getting
Facebook when I was in 8th grade okay
when I was in eth eth grade I got
Facebook and one of the first things I
realized in eth
grade is that there was stuff I wasn't
invited
to now please please please do not go
off and say make this a soab story about
Pearl but okay what I found out was
oh I didn't even know people had stuff
and I wasn't invited to okay so this was
an over like you get so much more
information than you really need with
the ad like with the internet coming out
first smartphone 8ighth grade I think I
got my first phone when I was like 12
these kids
nowadays and you know I talked to
Christine I talked to girls like just
five years younger than me my sisters
are 10 years younger than me and I can't
believe the generational Gap we have
between the
two these girls have had social media
since they were
10 okay these women have had had an
overload of attention since they were
really young they've been told they are
special important and awesome by
everybody by their parents many times by
the church many
times you know these are not so a lot of
times what I see from tradcons is they
point me to you know
the what I see from tradcons is they
point me
to the evidence from you know 50 years
ago they'll say look Pearl Pearl Pearl
just go to church find if you pray every
single day your marriage will
last and I just thought to myself these
hoes are not praying every single
day I mean you could go to church and
they're notay every
day I mean so I was I thought about this
I thought if he misses a day then is he
does he deserve ve divorce
okay anyways anyways now this is not
saying necessarily that I think that's
bad
advice I never said that but I think
that's very risky advice in
2023 I don't think guys can just go sign
up to get married with a girl that
prays and then it's it's a sure thing
you're just set for life right
right I've seen a lot of hoes in church
I mean sorry
okay and what I see is the red pillars
and the tradcons
arguing and I see them
arguing about okay so okay I want to
start this debate started with this guy
okay okay also feel free to send a
cash app we are demonetized right now
you're you has a high body count dud
will be like dude nice I personally
speak out against male promiscuity I
think one of the worst problems in our
world is promiscuity in general I don't
support dudes like sleeping with a ton
of women a lot of guys are like if a guy
has a high body count dudes will be like
dude nice I just I think it's degenerate
still like a hot girl go for it yeah I
think it's degenerate personally
contributing to the problem exactly a
lot of influencers that are like yeah
women with high body counts are bad but
also you as a man should go get laid
much humanly possible it's like bro
you're literally advocating for men to
contribute to the problem you're
calling
okay now what I don't believe is that
the red pill one you never know who who
what red pill guys are they talking
about but
two do they say it's
necessarily bad or
good the volume's low I which one one
three
okay all the
way oh no one heard the video okay um
sorry guys I tell blessing you
know personally speak out against male
promiscuity I think up
more the you said you said
more okay
wait
okay I personally speak out against male
problem you just
okay that's where it was
before you told
okay oh my
go okay let me let me see if it's all
right
now oh I heard a cash app I heard a cash
app $
five Emily
Simpkins s kits thank
you guys I need every dollar I can right
now I'll tell you what these bills they
just keep coming
in not good still
what okay now is it good okay cuz I'm
being gaslit right now
okay okay let's see if it's good I
personally speak out against male
promiscuity I think one of the worst
problems in our world is promiscuity in
general I don't support dudes like
sleeping with a ton of women a lot of
guys are like if a guy has a high body
count dudes will be like dude nice I
just I think it's degenerate still like
a hot girl go for it like yeah I think
it's degenerate personally this
contributing to the problem with exactly
a lot of influencers that are like yeah
women with high body counts are bad but
also you as a man should go get laid as
much as humanly possible it's like bro
you're literally advocating for men to
contribute to the problem call I
personally speak out against male
promise
okay so you know this Chase I think his
name is Chase now I'd like to say this
is attacking the idea not the person
okay got no problem with him personally
okay none zero problem I hate it because
many times I accidentally start beef
with people when I give my opinions
nothing personal okay red peel
influencers so my first question is
Chase who are you talking
about I
mean because I don't really hear if you
look at the core red pill guys now who
are the core red pill guys the red pill
really is a bunch of guys that got
together weekly to solve their
problems um you know so that's my first
question who who are you talking about
women with high body counts are bad I
wouldn't even say bad have always
had a
purpose I but it does relate you know
men just don't want to date them and
it's not their problem to
fix it's not it's not your
problem you know if a chick that's what
she wants to do okay also red pill
influencers go get laid as much as
possible
sleep around with a bunch of women spin
plates and avoid marriage because it's a
scam it's degenerate hypocritical and
heavily contri contributes to the
Brokenness of our world take the Christ
pill
instead now here's my problem this stuff
sounds good okay it sounds good and here
here's the problem that sounds
wonderful that sounds
lovely but but do I think in 2023 it
works now I don't want you to
misconstrue this with my moral opinions
on
it my religious opinions I know that you
guys are not all
Catholics okay so I think it would be
weird to put a
Catholic of what you should do I am
looking at this from the point of
view of what I believe works for men
from what I've seen I'm not a pickup
artist I'm not a dating coach I'm none
of that this is just what I've seen work
for men and when men do not have sexual
experience or dating experience with
women I see them get taken advantage
of I don't see these virgin women today
that are super
traditional the ones that I see get so
much attention from Men that they are
not the same as the virgins
yesterday okay so this sounds
good it sounds
nice but what do I think is more true
okay we're goingon to go focus on what I
think is
true myON says Jesus can't save these
hoes and neither can you you tradcons
need to realize feminism is is here to
stay and it's not going anywhere adapt
to the new normal or keep getting
married by the church and destroyed in
the state if you have a child in this
country unfortunately guys you
automatically opting in to State
marriage so what do I think is true not
what I want to be true not what I hope
to be
true sorry guys myON myON myON okay um
okay so
then
okay then he goes
into and it's so crazy I couldn't
believe this I couldn't I couldn't
believe this you're deliberately
deflecting myON stand topic I never said
dudes need to be Captain SEO I said
influencers like you are hypocritical
degenerates who are perpetuating the
problem here you CR criticize female
promiscuity as do I but then you tell
men it's good to sleep with tons of
women never get married and cheat on
their girlfriends and wives you're
making the problem worth worse not
building a solution so why do men have
to bail women out of what they
chose seriously so women the women right
now have all the freedom that we want we
can do whatever we want okay and if
women are choosing to be single mothers
only fans models and and now
there are no wives what are Men supposed
to
do there are not uh let's say 20% of
women are wives 80% are not wives there
aren't enough wives to go
around I
mean you know what they're going to do
lifelong celibacy good luck with that
okay
anyways good luck selling that one okay
you're making the problem worse not
building the solution I'm not here to
adapt to feminism but I'm here to
completely destroy it feminism will only
be destroyed by returning Western
Civilization to a state of Godly
patriarchy which is how God designed the
world to work this is the solution this
is the Christ pill as a mus Muslim you
should understand things so myin comes
from the point of view
that we're commentators we're YouTubers
what indication do you guys have that
this is is we're going to be in
a what did he say uh now I'm not saying
this is a bad idea so don't don't take
that
but I mean for most people they live
average jobs let's say you're 30 years
old let's say a Myron's average audience
member is 30 years
old when is this I mean so when when is
the patriarchy like when is this
feminism going to be destroyed in in his
40s his 50s his
60s I mean should he just wait his whole
life until that
happens I mean like this sounds nice
maybe for like our kids's kids but I
mean the truth of the matter is you got
One Life to Live you know and
unfortunately unfortunately women are
master deceptor and a lot of times
guys they really need to be able to tell
the
difference but because I see a lot of I
mean guys put a one in the chat if
you've seen a guy in church marry a
born- again
virgin put a put a one in the chat okay
I mean let's put a two in the chat if
you've seen a guy like I mean you you
see guys in church get swindled all the
time now again now again this is not
what Pearl thinks is moral or immoral
this is me looking at even if a guy
wants to have a family okay he could bet
on finding this magical Angel virgin
girl uh Good Luck Good Luck like I've
interviewed over a thousand women guys
this isn't like I I did this yesterday
this isn't my hope you know
but but you guys have to have a little
bit of experience to be able to vet
women
properly that's and and some women are
so damaged that they really only just
deserve to be
concubines H now again this is not my
morality on it this isn't okay
now
myON he
says sorry okay you think women worked
since the 60s to regress give up
feminism and to follow the Christ pill
you're as delusional as the women you
debate I mean guys it before you get mad
before you get mad is is he
wrong is myON
wrong and I mean myON used to trigger me
a bit but like I kept you know time time
is the biggest
tell um the
reality what what now okay
the like the of the mic okay the reality
is that these MO modern women aren't
going to give an inch why would they
stop behaving the way they do when they
are rewarded for doing so guys you have
to think about how deep this runs we
make 80% of consumer buying
decisions is it
likely that the entire economy is just
going to turn
around the entire political
structure
I wouldn't bet on it and I don't I don't
mean this I I'm sorry I just
wouldn't
um okay and anyway so they can they can
get simps to give them traditional
treatment while still behaving like
in their Peak years they can get
the best of both worlds with zero work
and society incentivizes and rewards
them for doing so women can pretend to
be tradcons and switch up last second
and go back to feminist tactics and use
divorce to destroy a man the only way to
deal with this is to adapt to the new
normal because we're never going
back is he
wrong do you really think they can ban
birth control cell
phones I mean is is he
wrong put a one in the chat if you think
he's wrong put a two in the chat if you
think Myron's
right so what would what would an
example be of a modern
solution I thought about maybe marriage
licenses like driver's licenses that can
be renewed every eight years and then
you could opt out that's now I know I
know you guys are thinking Pearl but
marriage is supposed to be for life and
I know I've said you know I think
divorce should be banned and I I've I've
changed this opinion slightly because I
just don't I think there are so many men
trapped in miserable
marriages
um and I think a lot of women pull one
over on them and I don't think that's
fair so you know I mean I still
think I I don't think you should get
divorced but you know anyways this is a
man telling me that women are
permanently in charge of civilization
and there's nothing men can do about it
WTF guess the only thing we can do is
give up and engage in degenerate
promiscuity now this is my irritation
with this dude my biggest
irritation how is he shaming myON how
the hell shaming myON for this marriage
now correct when he is doing the exact
same thing okay the exact same thing so
this guy is saying you influencers are
such Hypocrites you guys are sleeping
with women you guys are you're doing
this
you're not a virgin but you're waiting
until marriage now correct I'm uh
continuing to do my best to uh maintain
abstinence was there
[Music]
a I have I will say I will say I am not
above Temptation no chase yeah dude it's
over it's over it's so over it is over
so to give people context
the last my understanding the last time
you were on or in previous shows you
were on okay you had been celibate for
two year two and a half years years
three years no longer Chase are you
saying that you hold on you broke your
celibacy CH Chase I fell into temptation
bro Chase my he was
tempted Chase I'm how does Andrew feel
I'm not mad I'm just disappointed you
think you
think turn up down
okay up a
little okay
so oh also couple super chats couple
super chats Jonathan bmer thank you for
the $10 Super Chat Louise thank you for
the $2 Super Chat and Zachary Benedict
thank you for the $10 Super Chat I again
I could not do what I do without you
guys you guys are amazing thank you
thank you for the support so
okay now let me get this straight so
this
guy I couldn't even believe it when I
saw this I thought what this guy oh dang
it go back okay I thought this guy that
had so much to say so much to say
okay um let me go back to this so much
to say about
myON now I want ladies I want you to pay
attention I want you to pay attention
because at
first at
first what
did at first what
did
myin wait hold on let me go
back the only difference between these
two guys because okay this guy's dating
he's sleeping with his girlfriend
whatever you could argue with less
degenerate but but I mean if they break
up the same thing happened he added a
body count to that chick so the only
difference between these two guys is
myON is actually being honest about what
he does where the other guy is lying
because he wants to look good that
that's the thing they want to look good
and I just I don't I don't really care
about that okay all right
so
um all right it's hypocritical
are you kidding
me oh my gosh
so and that's the thing okay half the
time these Christian guys before they
got married these Christian guys that go
on these podcasts and I'll tell you
because I know things behind the scenes
okay they're either doing the same thing
that every other guy's
doing or
or they did that before they got
married and so many men many
men find out that if women are not
sleeping with them they're sleeping with
someone else and so many men in order to
figure out who's actually interested in
them because they're sick of wasting
time and money for women that are not
virgins and actually waiting till
marriage guys guys only 2% of women
actually wait till
marriage I
mean you know uh this is the strategy
they use you could have your qualms
about it but you know I at least respect
myON for being honest okay because that
that was dishonest that was so dishonest
I couldn't even okay um okay
so okay myin says okay since you have
all the answers please explain how
you're going to have to make all modern
women in the US take the Christ pill
stop being homes hes and bring back
traditional virgins like it's 1920 I'll
wait
um he's
right he's right um I I have no problem
with traditional women asking for
traditional
treatment
but they are few and far between not
many exist
anymore um maybe in the country and most
men can't bet on
this and I'm not in the business of
selling dreams it would be so much
easier for me to just come here and say
I'm going to sell you guys a
dream I can't I can't do it because I
think it's
dishonest um so so let me know what you
guys think in the chat you know and a
lot of guys it's not even about sleeping
around for them it's just when you're
women don't like women don't
like men that like them too much and for
in 2023 it just signals to us that you
can't get chicks so if we get too much
interest it it turns us off women admit
this you can find Tik Tock after Tik
Tock after Tik tock so what do you guys
think they think huh let me go after a
couple different women and when they do
that they're shamed for until one sticks
around one proves that she's wife
material um and unfortunately in the
future we're going to see a lot of
polygamy um now we're already seeing it
really when you think of situationships
talking stages what is
that
polygamy uh men cheating women
cheating now that birth control is out
on the market the Reigns are
free women organize themselves into
Herms that's what we
do we're going to mate with 20% of men
so for men really it's getting in the
top 20%
or saying I don't want to I don't want
to take
part both answers I think make sense I
think some men are going to look at the
market and say this is too much work no
thank you makes sense I think that some
men are going to get jacked make a lot
of
money and then screw a bunch of chicks
make sense but it's interesting
because when I I've seen him on another
show and he was
saying oh these poor women they're I
can't remember exactly so I'm
paraphrasing but it was something like
these poor women that are just getting
used by these me
H maybe they're using the
men like men get so much shame for
optimizing their sexual strategy for
saying I want multiple
women but women are not shamed for
optimizing our sexual strategy and going
for the best top guy that we can
get there is no shame in that and I
don't think there should
be so you know I miss you guys a lot let
me know what you think I have a bit of
a you know a bit a bit of a nuanced
opinion on this stuff now and I want to
clarify guys this is not my moral
opinion I I I think in order to talk
about what works and what doesn't work
in this
Society you have to separate morality
because not everyone not everyone's a
Catholic not everyone's a Christian so I
I'm trying to separate the two so
everyone can have a conversation about
it and I can already hear all the
Christians and Catholics coming in and
saying Bible Bible Bible
okay I don't disagree with you
guys but not everyone's as religious as
you and we're trying to have an honest
conversation so I'm probably going to do
a call-in show about this topic on
Wednesday if it's still hot on Twitter
otherwise I might think of something
else um thank you guys very much for
watching and thank you for the cash apps
I'm going to check one more time to make
sure I didn't miss
any we got let me see
10 15 17 27
37 40 bucks 50 52 6 we got $62 up in
here thank you guys thank you let me
know in the chat
also any other cash app options we
should have like a
PayPal Pearl and Myon that's not
defeatist
mentality myON probably if I had to
predict he'll have a more successful
relationship than most of these tradcon
dudes because the tradcon dudes don't
understand female nature most of them
don't
um okay Andrew Wilson talks about a
men's rights Lobby group okay I've seen
that I think it's really a no offense I
love Andrew big fan big fan no offense
but I think it's a bit
arrogant there's a reason you
know why a lot of this stuff
hasn't been successful in the
past like I mean we've had 50 I mean
there have been
really respected men's rights advocacy
groups I can't remember the names off
the top of my head but they've been
really unsuccessful why because
politicians have to cater to the female
vote do you think it's likely they'll
repeal the 19th in my
lifetime I don't
know I don't think so as much as I do
love these shirts which get yourself a
women sh vote t-shirt in the description
though I am saying you know um I'm not
in charge of the society I'm born into I
can't help
it so I don't let me know what you guys
think in the comments make sure you
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell feel free to send a
cash app even if it's after the show
like the video subscribe and I will talk
to you guys next time